I'm gonna take a picture of y'all
showing up here on a Saturday morning
cuz if I didn't get Instagram didn't
happen right actually I don't have an
Instagram account so that's how
old-school I am and today
Rober not gonna talk about how open data
science opens the world of innovation
and there's a lot of opening there a lot
of banging too but you know really to
start with I think it's good to sort of
back up a little bit and look at a high
level you know we're here at a PI data
conference the 23rd PI data conference
major Contee I did a conference in the
last four years so it's actually really
really cool and in we're here to talk
obviously about data science and Big
Data and all the stuff but I think it's
good to at least have the articulation
and and and to think about this this
framing that right now the world is
really on the cusp of a data revolution
even though you know Hadoop is 10 years
old and we were talking about big data
for what seems like an eternity now we
really are just at the beginning of what
I would call the data revolution just
like I think in the 90s one through the
internet and kind of the
telecommunications revolution right now
we are in the very at the very beginning
of a data revolution and it's no
surprise to any of you probably that
data is everywhere and it's going to be
even more and more dense everywhere and
this poses a problem of course with lots
of people poses opportunities too but
one of the things that I think it's good
to look at and ask ourselves as well
what's the problem data is everywhere we
can make lots of computers right and
also we can just make computers faster
right that's actually a question I get
sometimes why don't we just make
computers faster and because a lot of
the challenges we face really is because
computers are slow relative to the size
the data and relative of the things we
want to do with that data and this
little chart really lovely little chart
shows the generations of processors and
processing capability and it shows how
things really leveled off in terms of
frequency in terms of the amount of
power you could really pump into a chip
and all that really started tapering off
in the in the towards the end of the the
the 2000s and in around 2010 it was
clear that we're all going to be living
in a parallel
computing world a distributed computing
world where knockers gonna be able to
make a single big big fat chip anymore
and and the the challenge there you know
the reason why that's structurally
different then simply writing your code
and running on a faster chip well I
could just take the code and run on many
chips right now for people in this room
how many of you have tried to do any
kind of parallel or supercomputing you
have hands there you go how do you feel
like you really succeeded and done it
well awesome I'm gonna call you guys
down here at the end of the session now
so you know the challenges were
distributed computing peril computing is
hard and it's hard for kind of a weird
reason there's a really great quote that
I love from this particular general
general Barrow and he said when it comes
to military amateurs think about tactics
but professionals think about logistics
you know the tactics of how someone
hides in a bush somewhere to shoot
someone else or how you fly these planes
in to bomb this thing whatever that's
all for the amateurs the professionals
think about how do you keep those
soldiers fed how do you get bullets to
them how do you take the wounded
soldiers out of the combat situation all
of those logistics the trucks are
actually the more important thing you
know the tanks have the big explosions
the trucks are the more important thing
that win the war and so in a similar
vein when it comes to programming I I
want I like to say that amateurs think
about functions but professionals think
about bandwidth and it's really that's
the challenge is that when you're faced
with a parallel or distribute computing
situation you now have a topology of
things that are connected by very
different heterogeneous bandwidth
heterogeneous latency sort of
interconnects and in in thinking about
that basically everything you knew about
computing if you're at the age which I
the kind of the median age of this room
as I look around everything you've known
about computing basically is now wrong
everything you've known about computing
is actually not the most important or
the hardest problem and so the problem
is not that the data is that data is
everywhere the problem that we're faced
with nowadays is that everything around
the data is changing everything around
the data is changing if it was just big
data okay that'd be a problem but we
could sort of work that out the problem
is that all this other stuff is there we
have GPUs now that that are you know
have massive levels of performance and
and now we have people like am
telling us we should be thinking about
not computers and servers and things
like that or even networks of computers
but we should be thinking about
distributed and streaming computing
topologies elastically provisioned in
some magical cloud that they that they
own and every other vendor also has
magical clouds now that you can also buy
and then you have people creating
software technologies that want you do
is sort of on the one hand stop thinking
about the operating system on the other
hand deal a lot with operating systems
but whatever might be you're not just
writing code anymore you have to be
thinking about all of these different
things around it and if you think about
what Hadoop did to the data warehousing
market and the way fundamentally has
changed the conversation around that
that's one manifestation of one vertical
and the big broad complex IT space
Hadoop is only one vertical
manifestation of this level of
disruption everything else is also going
to be disrupted in a similarly
fundamental way as people actually have
to go and revisit and deconstruct 25 30
years of assumptions they've made so and
and the reason that's important for us
here in the data science community in
the data analytics space is that most of
the businesses in the world are running
at the core like beating heart or like
in the deepest you know part of their
brains the the analytics that they run
the way they think about their business
at an operational level or at a
strategic level those are driven by
ideas and by technologies that are very
very very old and even things like numpy
which might be new to some of you and I
certainly here in the in the broader
marketplace people about all these new
data science technologies like Python
and numpy and it's like well it's not
that new anymore right and and you know
one thing I don't have on here of course
I don't have Excel but Excel really is
also from the 70s right because visicalc
it does not change tremendously from
visicalc which came around the seventies
so the way we think about the world the
way we think about asking questions and
getting answers to them from computers
that is it's it's all based on old stuff
which has been built on a bedrock of
computational infrastructure and
computer science and systems and all
those things that are all totally stable
for a long time but all of those things
are changing now and so it's not that
we're in the middle of the data
revolution is that we're actually in the
middle of the the everything revolution
and so the data is revolution is really
just beginning but technology innovation
is accelerating because all of the
things around data is changing are
changing and every aspect of how we
ingest the data how we're gonna store it
how we're gonna manage it how we compute
on it all of that is changing and so to
go into a little more detail give you a
little more color around the kinds of
foundational like plate tectonic level
changes that are happening in the
computing landscape Robert we'll go
through some of the really cool things
I've been working on at Intel and and
just talk a little bit about you know
each of those things and and the the
potential I would encourage you guys to
think about how those things could
fundamentally change how you're thinking
about your problems how are you thinking
about your data
hi okay that works
I'm Robert Cohen from Intel and I'm also
from Boston area and my co-workers
didn't tell me I needed a joke so um I'm
gonna work on one real quick but this
bang reminds me that I was giving a talk
last year in the middle of talk everyone
was cheering and clapping in the middle
even parts I didn't think about amazing
and later I found out that World Cup
soccer was going on and everyone in my
audience was live-streaming soccer at
the same time so that's my joke okay and
so as Peter said a lot of things are
changing and so Intel you know data
science especially machine learning are
it's an important area for Intel we
think that maybe 20% of the the world
servers will be dedicated to machine
learning to bigness of Rus and we're
putting a lot of effort into making it
faster and I picked out some of the
technologies that we're developing that
I think would have a big impact on on
data science and machine learning
specifically especially deep learning
and you know some of the things are not
totally new but are becoming more
relevant and I'll explain why so the
first is this FPGA and FPGA is a field
programmable gate array and instead of
programming it with code like Python or
C code you can actually program it by
laying out the hardware the the adders
and the multipliers and the registers
and things like that and so that's the
software for that for that FPGA and so
the reason why that's interesting is
that you can really make if you have an
algorithm well-known algorithm
well-defined algorithm you can actually
lay out that data path for the algorithm
with the ads and all that and just have
just that part of your algorithm in the
hardware and not all this other stuff
that we have to normally put in to to
make your program work so you can
customize it to the operations you need
the data widths and so forth and so you
can make something really really
efficient with higher throughput because
there's more parallelism and and lower
latency
and so if PJ's are not new they've been
around for about 25 years and what's
actually changed is that
Intel's integrating the FPGA into the
package with the CPU so instead of FPGA
being some exotic hardware where you
have to build a whole board around it to
use it you it'll be in the system so you
know they'll be acceleration for things
like deep learning in the FPGA that'll
be in the cpu and so probably will
definitely from Python you'll be able to
just get the benefit of that kind of
acceleration that's really customized to
the application and analytics I think
would be a big part of that and so you
know here are some of the domains where
where it's be useful and ok this order
is a little different from mine ok let
me just go ahead one so so so here are
some examples where today where epi J's
are being used for a data centric
application and this is not the
integrated one but the one that you can
buy today where it's a separate chip so
these are big companies they're able to
build their own hardware but in the
future would be accessible to everyone
and so Microsoft is using FPGAs
to accelerate search and so for a 10%
increase in power they can double the
performance of the throughput in search
so it's a really powerful way to make
things faster you could buy 10 twice as
many servers use twice as many power but
you can also use FPGAs and it's much
more efficient and for Oddie
the the morality they're they're
incorporating a few days into the
autonomous driving and so for there the
problem is that the when you're in a car
you can't plug into the wall and so you
have to be power efficient and so FPGA
is make a lot of sense there so for for
autonomous driving which is driven
mostly by deep learning it's it's really
a gonna be a big change
okay and this is just some more detail
and FPGAs and you know deep learning
this is the older version of my slides
maybe I'll I'll switch yeah okay do this
quick
and the next thing I want to talk about
is 3d crosspoint so 3d crosspoint
okay so 3d crosspoint is a new type of
memory technology and it looks a little
bit like storage and a little bit like
memory it's sort of in between so if you
have a laptop today you have RAM inside
the laptop probably have 4 gigabytes
maybe 8 gigabytes of memory and that Ram
you know when things fit and RAM things
are fast but it doesn't fit in RAM
either doesn't work or it's just really
slow and another part of the system you
have a hard drive on the other end the
hard drive instead of being 40 gigabytes
can be 500 gigabytes or a terabyte or
something really huge and so which is
great but a hard drive is literally 10
is really literally a million times
slower than your RAM so you can imagine
when things are in the hard drive it's
hard to make things fast sometimes you
can do it but it makes it things
difficult then there's something called
SSD solid state disk so a lot of people
have laptops today with cells safe disk
inside and it's a lot lot faster and it
has similar density to the hard drive
maybe just a few hundred gigabytes it's
a normal size and it is a lot faster
maybe a hundred times faster than your
hard drive but it's still ten thousand
times fast slower than the RAM so when
things don't fit in RAM even with an SSD
things are going to be slow and so with
3d crosspoint it has similar density to
the an SSD so you can have a 3d
crosspoint with a few hundred gigabytes
maybe a terabyte and but instead of
being ten thousand times slower like the
SSD is it's about 10 times slower than
Ram and within a factor of 10 and so you
you really were used to sooth to times
improvement every two years so if you
get from hardware but you really get a
10 or a hundred times improvement which
is what you're getting with the 3d
crosspoint so you can treat it as
storage because it's persistently turn
off the power the bits are still there
or you can treat it as memory and it has
different aspects for different
applications this is looking at the
performance of taking a an SSD and
replacing it with 3d crosspoint
and which we call obtain on the left is
the latency
so Peter talking about throughput but
also latency is important for perils and
as well and that's where a lot of the
things I'm talking about today make a
big difference so the the latency of an
access of an SSD is about 90
microseconds and with opt Ain it comes
down to about 10 10 microseconds the the
the pink stuff here is the software
overhead so you notice that the software
overhead doesn't go down we just changed
the hardware the software still there so
the software overhead is really limiting
the benefit you get from this new 3d
crosspoint memory if you treat it as a
disk so if you Knights to get rid of
that software overhead and the software
if it's coming from the kernel and the
drivers and stuff like that which is
can't just be eliminated totally and
still be a disk but if you treat the 3d
crosspoint as memory I said it could
have bill either way it's fast enough to
be memory then you can get rid of this
software overhead and you can see that
the access time goes down to almost
nothing so now you can imagine if you
can have a like a few hundred gigabytes
to up to a terabyte of memory your
system instead of eight gigabytes or 128
gigabytes that you can have today for a
big server you can fit a lot more data
in memory you can access it you know ten
ten to one hundred to a thousand times
faster than you can today if it's in
disk and that really will enable a lot
of optimizations and innovations for
data science and as Peter said it's it's
probably people here he'll be developing
those algorithms or finding those
applications that could really benefit
and it's a really a big opportunity that
rarely happens in inner career and so
we've done some simple experiments
graphlab is a is a a graph database that
can handle data that doesn't fit in
memory and so you can take graphlab and
just replace the hard disks with
obtained based SSDs and that'll make it
faster and they change the software or
more interesting is to take the graph
lab and to just instead of using
buffers that fit in memory conventional
memory use buffers that fit in 3d
crosspoint memory which can be like four
times bigger and so you can solve much
bigger problems and keep things in
memory and this is early work so i can't
show you any numbers but the results are
really promising this is some benchmarks
of
placing SSDs with opti Nesta cease and
for i/o intensive benchmarks not all
Python and you can see that things are
about four times faster with very little
really no change in the software in
parallelism you know Peter showed how
things flattened out in terms of the
frequency but actually the performance
continues to go up and the reason is
because this use of parallelism and so
everyone said they're using parallelism
and not using it successfully but I
think maybe you don't all realize that
things like numpy and SCI PI R parallel
under the covers and so if you're using
sy pi if using anaconda based
distribution then you are and you're
solving big problems and you are using
parallelism you just don't know it so I
think that's really you know a great
result that you know the Python and
especially the the numpy community made
happen and so so here's sort of the
hardware and the hardware side of that
in in maybe in 2000 you had a single
core processor and then Intel double
number cores at multi-core and today a
few months ago we released a processor
xeon phi with 70 72 cores in a single
socket and that those are not like
special-purpose processors
those are cores that it can actually run
Python and have a numeric pipe in them
so they can do heavy duty work and you
know Python numpy side PI will take
advantage of that with no change so I
think that's really a big you know a big
improvement that's happening much more
computational power in a single sock in
a single box and on the right hand side
is showing the vector instructions and
so in 2000 you could do for single
precision instructions in a single
instruction and that's increased by a
factor of eight over the last four
generations now you can do thirty-two
and there's actually two vector pipes so
you can do 64 and so it all multiplies
out so there's a huge amount of
computational bandwidth inside your
processor today and if you kind of
multiply all that out number of cores
times the Sindhi vector instructions
times multiple pipes then you'll see
that in a Xeon processor which is a
typical server process
today you can do 700 flooding point
operations in a single cycle if you have
the Xeon Phi you can do four point six
thousand floating-point operations in a
single cycle and fifteen years ago you
were doing four so you can see it makes
a big difference
okay so FPGA I covered and I'm just
gonna wrap up how much time do I have
two minutes okay okay okay so and so the
Intel it's working on the right-hand
side of this chart and I kind of explain
what's going on and so to enable that
hardware you need software so we do the
OS the compilers the libraries and all
that the li'l of a software and we've
been mostly focused on making that work
from C and Fortran and so from C and
Fortran things are in good shape but
we're ignoring Python we sort of assumed
that would happen and so companies like
continuum and other companies in the
Python community did a lot of the heavy
lifting but you know there's there's
sort of part that's our responsibilities
have been more involved in last year
we've been working closely with
continuum and we see that that anaconda
is like a way to deliver that
performance and I said that if you're
using Syfy today from anaconda you're
doing parallel processing you just don't
know it and so we're kind of really
focusing on that more in the past year
and making sure that all those things I
talked about before or at least you know
it can be accessed directly from Python
used automatically FPGA multi-core and
all that so all these things are coming
you don't actually have to do anything
new to take advantage of a lot of this
but I think it's going to open up new
problem spaces for you to solve that
maybe you couldn't solve before and I
think that's what's really so exciting
and just to show you some of the
performance results the the in this
chart here this is showing linear
algebra and FFT on the xeon processor
and the little bar here is performance
of if you just took a bunt to when you
installed a PD get the sidelines I'm
probably all that this is performance
you get and the blue is if the black is
if you're a little more sophisticated
you compile the Python stuff yourself
with using the default with open Blas
and higher is better and the blue is for
an anaconda bass distribution you can
see that it's it's really very close to
a hundred percent which is native
performance if you use C or Fortran so
from Python today you can really get for
certain algorithms that fit well you can
really get native performance without
having to hand code everything in C or
is somebody could and all that and you
can use multiple cores and the send the
instructions that I mentioned before and
this is the same kind of results for
scikit-learn with fifty percent to eight
times speed up this is this is a
principal component analysis PCA on
SPARC and there's a 10 times speed up
for that and here's one more result this
is showing the performance we took PCA
on SPARC and we implemented it with C we
implement it with Java we amendment with
with Python and this is performance you
can see they're all within 5 percent of
each other so it really shows that you
can really get great performance from
Python and you can take advantage of
multiple nodes on SPARC multiple cores
the vector instructions all there and
it's really really really you know
relatively easy compared to what it
could have been and I think that this
new computational power that I talked
about earlier in the talk will be
accessible to you and you really just
have to think of what the right problems
to solve in order to take advantage of
it and I think that that was it and this
is our optimized packages for Python
what I am hoping that you get a sense of
its just simply how much how much
amazing new things you're gonna see not
only coming now from the algorithm side
and you know the breakthroughs in deep
learning and things like that but at a
raw hardware level we things are
different now we're at a different phase
then we've been in for a you know for a
long time and what I'm what I'm
suspecting what I'm predicting is that
it will lead to something akin to like a
Bri an explosion in terms of the number
of different ways of trying different
kinds of techniques on different kinds
of hardware topologies and different
kinds of hardware configurations for
different kinds of problems like
everything is gonna get a lot more
heterogeneous a lot more variegated than
we've ever seen there's not you know at
this point and I still in a lot of when
I talk to users and customers and
potential customers there's always these
questions of well what is the best stat
what's the best thing to do for this
what's the best thing and we're gonna
hopefully you know everyone will start
realizing that you can't ask that
question like it doesn't make sense
because there is no single best thing
for everything you don't just take this
one thing and use it for everything
there's gonna be different approaches
different kinds of configurations for
different kinds of problems and that's
going to lead to some really rapid
evolution and so we saw sort of in the
Cambrian era as well and one of the
things that I like to one of the
metaphor is like a drop on is this idea
of you know companies that are are
operationalized on data science
companies that are moving quickly to
modern open data science they're like
you know those early life forms that
first started developing eyes it first
started taking gino's light-sensitive
cells turning them into photoreceptors
and then shaping them ultimately into
optical circuits that actually could
image and see when there was a predator
or where there was prey and you think
about the massive advantages that
creatures that could see that they had
versus creatures that couldn't and and
even if you have a crude eye and only
one of them you're still way better off
to something they can't see at all
there's just it's night and day
literally nine-day difference right you
can't even a pair and I think companies
nowadays are in similar way if there's
still
five years from now sitting there with
the Excel spreadsheets driving a bunch
of old reporting bi software they're
just gonna be there they're gonna be
like lunch for somebody but it's but
beyond just eyes if you think about what
eventually happened right as we all as
creatures evolved eyes and we move
forward it was important that those eyes
actually took all of that input and was
able to synthesize them in a very
complex neural structure that could
process those things and so it's very
important think about our modern very
advanced visual systems it's not just
the eyeball not just the retina or the
fovea actually what makes vision amazing
is the fact that we have a visual cortex
that's able to learn and and and
synthesize all these things and is able
to connect that raw sensory input and
turn it into understanding and then make
predictions and accurate ones about the
world and so in a similar way I think
businesses as they grow and evolve in
this Cambrian era as they are able to
access you know 3d crosspoint as they're
able to think about new algorithms in
FPGAs and work with research
institutions to develop new approaches
for for old problems on this new amazing
Hardware one thing that we have to sort
of think about is how does that though
all the technology aside how does that
actually synthesized into something how
does that turn into something that that
at an organizational level a company or
even a country can actually they can
actually you know not just have to be an
Oracle not just having magic not just
have it be some you know super uber sky
mind thing that tells you what to do
what we actually need is to have a
really good interaction of symbiosis
between all this technology all of these
data sensors data collection methods and
all the people who can actually make the
judicious calls who can actually ask the
right questions and know which questions
are better than other questions and so I
predict that in addition to us entering
this era of the this data revolution
that we're actually entering an era of
data literacy where the ability to think
statistically the ability to think and
understand about models and how flawed
every model must invariably be the
ability to explore data and talk about
that that is a new kind of literacy that
will be
for any field whatever field you're in
whether you're in government whether
you're in genomics whether you're an
astrophysicist it doesn't really matter
you are going to be swimming in data and
the only way to not drown well you're
gonna be covered in data urea wash in
data that's right metaphor you're
washing data the only way to not drown
is a little how to swim and and that is
this data literacy concept and I and you
know just like now most people can type
and everything it's just a sort of a
computer skills typing skills that's
just part of the game so I think in the
in the coming era we're going to see
that the ability to think statistically
the ability to know what's possible
computationally that's a part of your
literacy as a high functioning
professional in any field and and one of
the things about that though the reason
I use the word literacy and it's a very
intentional choice the reason I use the
word literacy is because language
ultimately is a human instinct and it's
a natural for i thing for us for the way
our brains are wired it's a natural path
to insight and when I talk to people to
use Python and when and whether it was
you know early on in my career and and
everyone's just talking about the Zen of
Python and and how you know it's it just
sort of works and it's like executable
pseudocode and all of the wonderful
things people say out Python ultimately
it was an expression around this concept
that there's actually low impedance
mismatch between how we think about
things and how we're able to then code
our ideas and so that expressiveness and
agility I think is a key feature of
Python and it's a one of the best and
beautiful things and one of the
challenging things however is that it's
a really hard thing to to just defend
you don't have just like a CI process
running for every commit that says was
this code expressive was it beautiful no
sorry you can't commit that you can't
merge that commit you know if we had
that tool be great it's but but it is
such a it's sort of a wishy-washy sort
of like if they're a very fuzzy thing to
defend but it is a principle nonetheless
that that we've always defended in the
Python world and I think will continue
hopefully you know carrying that torch
forward and so you know the punchline of
that is that if you actually are able to
give people give human brains the
ability to to seize upon their language
instinct you're able to give them
something that is computational in
addition to that you can take that
language instinct and connect it to
computers then what you have is not just
software it's not just a VM and a
runtime and
the Gil and alls other stuff it's
actually thought where it extends the
reach of the mind in the same way that
mathematics extends the reach of the
mind we now have to do math on certain
kinds of hardware certain kinds of
computational systems and the way to do
that math the way to think and reason
within that kind of that kind of scope
is to use a language in a language that
lets you both think as well as compute
and a slide that I really really love is
for people who don't know much about
Python for hopefully many people in this
room I see if you're nodding heads this
is sort of like oh yeah of course this
is my lived experience but many people
who come and ask me well what's the
difference in Python and bash you know I
have to show this slide and the
difference right is that most of us who
can see the spectrum of different kinds
of people
there's programmers who know how to
write code to understand code to
understand software architecture and
then there's analysts who understand
domain problems who understand the
texture of the the business problem
they're trying to solve but they really
can't code it all and they tend to be
more Excel users bi tools you know
visual tool users over here programmers
they have an editor and that's really
they're fine with that actually and in
the middle we have this emerging class
of people most of you in this room I
think probably fit in the middle and you
are not writing code just for codes sake
nor are you just sitting there clicking
around hoping that the tool someone
built 30 years ago will give you the
answers you need we laugh but we should
be crying right it's true and so and so
in the middle you are going to produce
code that produces insight and that's an
amazing thing and the even more amazing
thing is that you don't have to learn
some new weird thing you can actually
use Python and it spans both if you make
a jupiter notebook if you make a small
Python script that doesn't excel query
pull some stuff you know changes some of
the fields around and then sums it and
computes a mean or something you can
take that script to an excel user and
they've never taken cs101 they don't
know malloc I'm a free from a hole in
the ground but they can probably edit
that script and change it to query for
two weeks ago as opposed to last week
the ability to riff off of your code is
an amazing thing and that lets that
Python be very viral as a technology
within firms at the same at the same
point you can take the Python code and
give
to your back-end Java or Ruby programmer
at your organization and they might not
know the details of everything about the
syntax but it basically can make sense
to them it makes a lot more sense than
if it's ass or MATLAB code and they know
how to deploy it they can sort of Google
around and look in Stack Overflow and
figure stuff out and the fact you can
use one language not only to express
your ideas your mathematical statistical
computational ideas to us are your
domain ideas you can express that to the
computer but you can also express it to
other people and so it really can be a
unifying bridge and and the reason
that's so important is because based on
everything I've seen in real life real
world situations data science is always
a team sport data science always is not
it's little silos the ivory tower just
schlepping insights off to the rest of
the business unless the organization
data signs the team sport there's people
of varying degrees of skill even within
the data science just the data science
practice but data science is always
interacting with and contextualized in
the middle of a bunch of business
questions business operations as well as
a whole bunch of IT and software and an
IT infrastructure and so it's important
for us as we as we move forward into
this Cambrian era of all these
technologies everything it's important
for us to consider what that
heterogeneity means what that disruption
means a lot of these people are going to
be used to tools and they're not use of
those tools changing a lot of people
over here don't care about tools and
there have to start caring about tools
and so data scientists actually by being
multi sort of a hyper spectral group you
actually can be a glue you know python
is a glue language data science actually
can be a glue community bringing all
these people together into this new
world of computing and that community
concept is incredibly powerful and this
slide it's a simple slide only five
numbers on it but it's actually a really
amazing slide if we think about the fact
that just how many you know we start a
continuum four years ago four and half
years ago anaconda is about four years
old at this point
and the number of downloads are just
skyrocketing I mean more and more people
most of you probably don't download a
new anaconda release probably is kind of
update right but more and more people
are downloading anaconda every day like
it the second
is positive and that and I can say that
to this crew to this group and so what
that means viscerally is that my
bandwidth bill is actually starting
become pretty daunting but uh but
actually you know it means that we're
gonna have more people entering the data
science community that are new that are
new to Python maybe new to computing in
general and they're at universities and
colleges they may be longtime
professionals who've been doing data
analysis for a long time and they're
finally they're like okay I got to get
into this data science thing and they
get a book and they get anaconda and
they start learning how to do some basic
things and so the user community is
growing and it's folks like yourselves
are to come out to a PI data conference
on a Saturday it's folks at Capital One
that you know that that's sponsored
these things that are key drivers in
this they're gonna make this actually be
a powerful movement and it's it's really
amazing to look back this is not even
all the talks there's just a small
smattering of them I don't believe
there's any duplicates but this is we
got four years we're 23 conference 23
conferences now those 23rd and in
hundreds and hundreds of talks from
people the the community around PI data
is absolutely amazing and the talks I'm
not able to go to all the events and
even when I do I'm not able to go to all
the talks but as I look at as I watch
the videos afterwards there's a look at
the even the proposals that come in you
know ones that we fortunately can't
accept because we don't have enough time
all of them are just it's it's so
amazing to see that the power here and
and that that power is a you know the
the idea that we have a community I
think is of a central one here in the
Python data science space but but the
the key aspect of it what's what makes
it click for people I think is this idea
of empowerment that people actually when
they're equipped with these tools with
these open data science tools when
people are able to get the data they
need and they're able to go and run
whatever computation they need there's a
deep sense of empowerment and and it's
it's actually you know something that
you know the the as we move forward and
we have a world that's more connected a
world that has more more sensors more
data available as more policy questions
shape the nature of our world as more of
those policy questions are answered by
data drop on data we're going to find
that this data literacy concept this
this
be one of those times when we either
create a two-class society where we have
people who understand how all the
technology works people who understand
how the data analytics comes around that
drives the policy or we have you know if
you'll don't or we have a world where
everyone was very democratic and
everyone can have access to it and so
one of the deep goals for the reason why
we made anaconda the reason why we
believe in open data science is that our
world is going to be shaped by decisions
by statistical models by algorithms that
some of you here may be pioneering and
that world in in a just world in a good
world that world and and all those kinds
of mechanisms should be transparent and
accessible to everyone they should not
require some expensive proprietary
license for someone to understand why
their tax bill is this or why they're
denied this insurance claim because they
were part of some cohort that some
intern messed up right they should we'll
look at those models that transparency
and that accessibility ultimately is
about empowerment and it's ultimately
fundamental to the nature of democracy
into the world that I think we want to
live in but this also you know it poses
business challenges there's a long hill
to climb a long slog a lot of fights to
be had but ultimately I think we're on
the right side of history in actually
you know every time in history if you
look back over the thousands of years of
human history every time that literacy
or some some concept like literacy has
been broadened to the masses it's
created so much prosperity it's created
so much wealth relief so much suffering
and in all those situations
there's just no argument which side of
history you should be on I think right
now right now in the in mid-2010 we are
at that kind of moment in history and
we're right here sitting on top of some
technologies whether it's hardware
whether it's software
we're sitting here and we can be
champions of technologies that are open
that are democratic that are accessible
and empowering and so I think those
fights are worth fighting and I think
that you know we're just getting started
pie data the concept itself is only four
and a half years old the community is
actually much older than that but
they've all rallied around this banner
that's only four and a half years old
and the diversity of experience that we
get from newcomers is absolutely one of
our core strengths and that's something
that I want to reiterate to all of you
whether you're new or whether you
for a long time there's going to be if
we're successful the very definition of
success the visceral feeling of success
is that you're always surrounded by
people who don't know what they're doing
because they're new because that means
you're a gaining mass and gaining
community and gaining momentum if you're
only ever surrounded by the same people
you've always known then you're in a
dying technology space you're in a
community that has atrophied or
plateaued at best so the visceral
experience of Pi data the visceral
experience for you as pythonista
in this community is that you are going
to be interacting with new people all
the time and I would encourage you and I
would just reiterate that that openness
and the welcoming nature of Python
itself as a value but also to the PI
data community that that open and
engaging nature is core to what's gonna
make us successful as a technology and
ultimately as a movement as a community
so open data science not only languages
not only hardware but actually it's
about empowering people to answer the
questions about the world that they have
it's about inviting everyone into the
tent it's a big tent and I've been
talking about Python a lot but of course
in anaconda we have R and we have
support for SPARC many different things
and so it's not only language centric
but the Python community is certainly
where the one of the few technology
communities I've seen that really treat
that openness and the welcoming and
inclusiveness you know treat those
values as being a core value and so we
in the PI data community also have an
obligation to continue extending that
and that's really if we just do that I
think we're very very successful I think
would have an amazing impact on the
world thanks to all of you here the
speakers sponsors and and organizational
business partners we're going to help
bring about this age of this the age of
data but do in a way that is open and
that is accessible to everyone thank you
very much
you